the problem is when I probably my the
problem I had the problem I have would
be the entertainment before it they give
you questions to ask and you have to ask
them or literally it could be your job
so they float out like a bunch of real
dumb ones do they give you any room to
like oh yeah you could do whatever you
want but they'll be like hey you gotta
ask this question and it's like if
somebody just got divorced you gotta be
like hey what happened divorced yeah and
it sucks yeah yeah ask women that yeah
that's why I stopped doing it man I
couldn't one time what's her name Anna
what's her name she was in Devils were
Prada not Meryl Streep but an Anne
Hathaway so they gave me the dumbest
question and I had the way Kim
Kardashian Kanye West were on the cover
of Vogue and right before that it was a
in hathaway and so they told me they go
hey why don't you ask her what she
thinks about the cover because everybody
was like oh this is bullcrap that Kim
Kardashian's on I asked Anne Hathaway
that question and she goes well you know
I don't run the magazine so it really
doesn't matter to me I'm like fine
so I finished the question I'm walking
down the stairs and go they're not here
she goes
why the fuck would he ask me that
question I don't give a shit who's on
that magazine and I was about to turn
back around cuz I kind of got mad but
now I was like man she's fucking right
that was a dumbass question maybe you
could say I'm sorry they made me ask you
have questions yeah it's too late and
it's too late yeah that's a projects to
padieu sirs like winding you up like a
little robot click click click get out
there ask the questions don't ask yeah
they get so babble oh yeah yeah they
threaten your job with it well that's
why those shows are always soaked and
you know we don't have people talking to
entertainers and everything's soaked and
it just seems so inauthentic like they
wanted me to ask my first interview ever
was with Jennifer Aniston at Marley & Me
and this is right after she broke up
with Brad Pitt didn't want you to ask
about Brad they wanted me to ask
and I was like no I can't do that did
you tell him no no I know is my first
gig so he's not - so no I didn't so I
said what if I figure out a different
way to ask so I found so what they're
like whatever you get we need
clip you know and this was when I was at
a entertainment and this is my first big
shoot ever Jennifer Aniston and they
were like you're gonna go out there so
it was Marley & Me so she just broke up
with Brad Pitt so I go
since the movies about a dog I go what's
the what's the what's the similarities
between a dog and a man and she laughs
and gives a great answer about you no
one will be around but a dog is always
forever you know like men could treat
you rut so I got a great answer
and I didn't have to ask about Brad Pitt
and that's the thing is if you find a
smart way to ask it you can ask it but
they just sometimes want you to be just
so brutal it's it's I can't well it's
because they don't have to do it and
they don't keep the relationships
exactly and they just don't care about
you you're a little trained person that
they send out a little mighty person
little person listen to me little person
you have to listen the person who signs
the paper yeah let's send you off and
give you a little fucking direction oh
it's the grossest I mean it is amazing
because I got to build relationships
with people but like good for you for
recognizing it Oh a hundred percent
hundred I knew they were doing so what
you I mean not I mean that but I
recognized you got to get out of it Oh
100% it's like my soul couldn't I
couldn't ask people about them breaking
up or something tragic happening in
their lives like how are you doing now
is going to some of them TMZ dudes that
feel bad I'm like look bro I feel bad
too but I'm not talking to you like yeah
there's nothing good ever comes out of
these like it's no disrespect to you I
know you're doing a job I'd probably do
the same job if I was in your place
probably yeah if I was a kid when I was
a kid if TMZ was around I take that job
yeah just try to ask some famous dude of
a funny question but it's just like it's
not the way to discuss things know
discuss things and you're coming out of
the airport or you're on your way to a
fucking restaurant somewhere and someone
sticks a camera in your friends like
come on well I wasn't doing that that
was I was we were going to junk it TMZ
oh yeah yeah yeah like but I mean
there's these these junkets are a brutal
assault on
reality you're saying the same thing
over and over and over again you're
asking this everyone asks you the same
question
you know tell so tell us about this show
yeah Michael you play play Michael yo
this is your real name this is crazy